as we mentioned we're getting ready to
release our film goodbye promise one
thing that we wanted to do that we
thought would would kind of be fun is to
incorporate a pitch video with the
release just just is another way to kind
of draw attention to the thing I think I
think a lot of filmmakers and artists
they don't necessarily utilize video as
much as they should and so we just want
to kind of pick your brains because we
love the way you guys released your
Kickstarter campaign for dying to do
Letterman and it was professional from
day one all the way through the end and
just anything you can you can give us in
terms of what we should be thinking
about with the pitch video we may put
together well I think number one the
most important thing is to start from a
place of passion I think I could
probably I would not have had a
successful Kickstarter campaign we
would've had a successful Kickstarter
campaign if we weren't truly 100%
passionate about the film because your
passion I think will come through in any
type of promotion you do video to me
seems like the biggest no-brainer of all
time for filmmakers but a lot you know a
lot of filmmakers that for whatever
reason either their gun shy about
getting on camera or they don't want to
come off as you know arrogant or pompous
or you know what all that all the
typical you know ways that people like
to think of you know crazy filmmakers
the truth is if you care enough about
your project to you know sweat blood and
tears to get it done you should care
enough to tell people why and I think
that if you start from a place of
honesty and passion and however you're
communicating it all you'll already be
ahead of the pack I think the mistake
then a lot I see a lot of indie film
makers make when they start making some
sort of tape is that they'll try to
maybe like ape or copy a different
campaign that was successful but that
may be completely inappropriate for what
it is they're doing it more often than
not you watch a filmmaker and you go who
cares you know I you know I don't care I
bet you a lot of the filmmakers when
they watch that own tape they probably
know it probably doesn't move them but I
think if you again if you start from a
place of honesty and and you you create
something that's as real as the movie
you made in the first
it's something as personal and cool and
quirky and interesting as your own work
people are gonna respond and I mean
listen I'm a big sound but I when I
watch our Kickstarter video I still tear
up and you know yes part of it is cuz I
have to admit that I looked at goofy on
camera but part of it is because I
really I really do it the journey meant
so much to us that it was impossible not
to be passionate when we talked about it
so I think my first tip would be
starting from a place of honesty passion
what you're saying is yeah I'm getting
it in order no I I know what it is
anyone my second tip is but go ahead I
thought you might want to expand um
expand on the passion no I absolutely
agree we we're working with some
filmmakers now who are doing a
documentary called journey through fire
and they actually came in and one of the
video things that they're doing which I
thought was really nice is they're
talking to different filmmakers and
having them almost pitch to film where
you know to me what is it that inspired
to them about the film or what is it
that inspired stab them about the
project which I think again to the
passion that it's not just a filmmakers
passion but to show that the film has
inspired a passionate response and
others I think definitely helps in terms
of having you know testimonials you know
within the pitch video which is not
something we did but I saw them doing it
just recently we're working we do
different titles of testicles right but
you know for them it really I mean
they're still in the editing process
they don't have their film finished yet
you know we saw a rough cuts and little
bits and pieces and you know found out
about the stories and all of that but
you know again it's speaking to the
passion it's just what's your passion if
you know if I'm an audience member and
you know you're the filmmaker of course
you're passionate about your project but
to see somebody else get passionate
about your project who's not necessarily
connected to it in any way that's
intriguing and then I go oh you know
what what is in your project that sparks
their passion
that may also then spark mine and I
think a 1/1 idea that you're hitting on
there that I do think is important if
you're lucky enough to have it is social
proof you know basically proof that
there is a love of your project outside
your own love you because of course you
love her do you wouldn't have you know
spent all your money and all your time
making it we were so lucky to that when
we played our initial festivals that we
were not only winning but we were
getting standing ovations and and we we
brought cameras with us to the
screenings in hopes of gathering some
type of audience reaction and far
exceeded our expectations but being able
to show people our film is receiving one
standing ovations after another and
people in the lobby are unable to
contain themselves and there and there
they're crying and talking about the
film and this is what real people are
saying about the movie I think lent a
lot of credibility and it also made
people feel good about supporting the
film whether it was donating or watching
or deciding to buy a ticket it's like
well there's other people in the world
are being moved by this movie that only
said not only says to me that it's good
it also says to me this is something I
want to be a part of you know am I
missing out by not seeing this film is
it we know in my life you know maybe be
touched like that person's life was
touched if I took the time to go see it
or it not all movies are needed to be
touching it could be a comedy you know
am I gonna have that much fun at the
movies you know is it worth me going to
escape for a few hours so I do think
that if you can hint that social proof
in any kind of pitch you do it for
anything just proving that there's
there's a more universal you know
attractiveness to your project I do
think that will help the next point that
I think is is is really important and I
think this speaks to again and it
doesn't matter if you're making a movie
if you're selling widgets you know if
you're you're trying to get booked to
give speeches or whatever I think you
have to know your audience you know it's
really important to know that audience
and to speak to them and and I don't do
that necessarily mean a lot of people
will go oh well who's your audience and
I know all I'm asking start breaking it
down into demographics I don't think
that necessarily works as well for
independent filmmakers I mean yes it's
important to know in general you know
this movie is going to appeal to men
more
women or vice-versa but a lot of times
indie filmmakers fall into this weird
in-between place because we're making
something that's different and it
doesn't necessarily fit one specific
walled so I think you want to figure out
how to appeal to certain pieces of
everybody I mean I think we all have you
know in the case of dying to do
Letterman I think we all have an
underdog spirit no matter who you are in
a matter if you're a man or woman no
matter what age you are all of us at
some point in our lives have been the
underdog or rooted for an underdog and
that was something we worked really hard
to tap into when we you know Wonder
reach died and that was not only
reflected in our video which very
clearly said no one wanted us to make
this movie which was true people said it
you know it was a horrible idea to shoot
the film people thought we were crazy to
invest our money in it I mean we were
underdogs Steve's story is a major
underdog story so by saying the people
you know look we're underdogs we part of
our underdog story I think that helped
them relate to the movie I think if you
can find something that's universal in
your film and be and think of that as
your demographic what's my demographic
it's underdogs we all have a little
piece of the underdog in us so in a way
it makes it easier to focus your message
like like you're tapping into that
essence as opposed to I'm just going for
the you know eighteen and thirty year
nine year old male which probably if
you're independent filmmaker you
probably don't fit a category quite so
sharply unless you set out to make a
commercial film which is a whole
different business plan altogether so
when we apply I think yes that's a whole
side I think unfortunately I think a lot
of independent filmmakers get lumped
into what you'd only make one kind of
movie which is not true an independent
filmmaker as a person that goes and
makes a movie with their own money
because no one else will pay for it you
know I think that if Sloane went out and
they did their independent version of
Armageddon god bless I'd supported 100%
I do think there's a bias against you
know young aspiring filmmakers who tend
to make stuff that appeals to the masses
as opposed to the niche audiences so for
the record I completely support anybody
and applaud anybody who has the gumption
to finish a movie and if your movie
happens to the Armageddon or a horror
movie or a comedy and it doesn't fit
your typical you know festival festival
model it's I I don't think people should
care I think you
be applauding for finishing your film in
the first place so that's a whole rant
for another day
you